[Musique]
on
bonjour je m'appelle eric languet je
suis chorégraphe avant tout danseur et
pédagogue de danse contemporaine et de
danse intégrante
ça fait un peu plus 40 ans que je danse
j'ai commencé la danse à l'île de la
réunion où j'ai grandi
et puis après j'ai fait une carrière qui
m'amenait de l'opéra de paris au ballet
royal de nouvelle zélande avant de
revenir à la réunion et d'installer la
compagnie danse en l'r dont je suis le
responsable artistique chorégraphe était
d'accord
j'ai rencontré un danseur professionnel
handicapés britannique qui s'appelle
david toul
c'est un monsieur qui n'a pas de jambes
qui a un corps complètement difformes et
c'est le plus beau danseur que j'avais
jamais vu de ma vie ça complètement
chamboulé toutes les notions que j'avais
sur l'esthétique sur le bo sûr qu'ils
pouvaient danser ou pas et tout ça et
j'ai vu et j'ai eu envie en revenant
dans ma compagnie de le partager avec
des gens et d'expérimenter voilà une
pédagogie qui permettent à des gens de
danser ensemble plein pour l'heure peu
importe leurs différences concept de
danse intégrante c'est d'être persuadé
que ce n'est pas le handicap qui définit
la personne humaine
mais c'est plutôt son environnement
humain et structurelles qui va définir
le taux de handicap de sept personnes
donc nous c'est notre mission qu'on
s'est donné en danse intégrante c'est de
justement changer cet environnement là
la première chose c'est de rendre
accessible la danse à tout le monde
aussi de pouvoir outiller les personnes
pour leur permettre d'être indépendante
et autonome et de réelles citoyens
conscients
je suis curieux du monde qui m'entoure
et je vais voir je vais essayer de
comprendre
je vais essayer de comprendre sans a
priori sans juger les gens à priori ou
les faits j'essaye d'être le plus neutre
possible voilà ce qui m'a permis aussi
de padt d'aller au delà de beaucoup
d'idées préconçues
par exemple sur le handicap et tout ça
une beaucoup plus grande implication des
personnes handicapées elles mêmes dans
leur prise en charge dans dans toute la
réflexion qui
keith porte sur sur le handicap sur la
citoyenneté et tout ça c'est beaucoup de
choses se font sans arrêt sans ces
personnes là et ça on vouloir plagié au
gandhi ou mandela qui disait que tout ce
que vous faites moi mais sans moi vous
le faites contre moi mais je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup plus à ce niveau-là
d'implication et de rechercher leurs
leur parole
[Musique]